i got four things one prices that go up
do not come back down chipotle put their
prices up four percent they ain't
bringing them back down right every
single one of these businesses that
increase prices they're not coming back
down that's real inflation that rate of
change inflation that's fine that's
great for uh people in the financial
community to talk about but the real
impact it's not going bad the second
thing is that when you think about the
supply chain the supply chain absolutely
is has issues there's backed up
ships in la there's all sorts of issues
but a lot of the supply chain issues
were driven because they gave everyone
free money and then they went and they
spent the money and they jacked up
demand and the supply chains weren't
ready to handle it so they broke the
supply chains that's the second thing
the third thing and i think one of the
pieces that everyone continues to forget
here
is that they are going to continue to
try to tell you not to believe the
numbers and they're going to try to
continue to manipulate the numbers
president joe biden literally came out
he knew what the number was going to be
and he came out and he said
tomorrow when you see the number you got
to remember that that doesn't
incorporate the the energy prices have
already been coming down
like they're telling you don't believe
the number
but in fact
you shouldn't believe the number but not
because they're overshooting or
overstating it it's because they're
understating
and the last thing and the thing that i
think is the most important is i
continuously get people they dm me they
email me they call me they text me and
they say pomp
i saw you and your brothers talking
about inflation what should i do
and they keep thinking about it from an
investment standpoint and there's a
bunch of things you can do there but the
number one thing that you can do and i'm
basically pleading with people at this
point
please please please if you do not own
equity or you do not have some sort of
profit share or you do not have some
sort of upside in your employment
situation
please
take these inflation numbers
go to your boss and say hey
i don't know how to really have this
conversation
but what i do know
is that the inflation is now 6.8 percent
which means i'm making less money today
than i was last year
i understand that you guys may not be
thinking about pay raises
or some sort of change to the pay scale
but inflation is so bad
that i need you to help me out what can
we do so that i can increase my pay
all i want is to simply be able to have
the same purchasing power that i had
last year i'm not asking to get paid
more money so that i can go buy a boat
or go on vacation or buy a new house
all i'm asking is that you afford me the
opportunity to come to work here every
day i do a great job for you all
and you continue to allow me to
withstand the exact same living
situation
because if you don't pay me more in
dollar terms i have less purchasing
power and i'm actually getting a
degradation of my living quality
and so if you bring them the inflation
data and you say i need a raise but i
need a raise simply to be able to combat
inflation that'd be seven percent
if they want to help you out even more
you may be able to get as high as 10
percent which for many people would be
very meaningful change to their
financial situation
so if you want to do this
my suggestion is you take the inflation
data
put it on your boss's calendar or get a
meeting and then do not ask for the
raise to start next week
instead say to them we're coming up on
the end of the year
can you please walk me through the plan
as to how we go from where i am now to
the pay raise and in many cases the
business want to plan in advance they'll
have to say hey well you know what we're
not gonna be able to get to that until
the end of q1
that may not be a good answer or maybe
it is a good answer for you that's for
you to decide but asking is the key
right now because you don't get what you
don't ask for
and you have the single greatest
argument in the world
right now
for a raise which is that inflation is
6.8 percent so go ask for a raise
i don't think bosses are gonna be really
willing to give out raises unfortunately
right because their margins are getting
squeezed so bad there's 11 million open
jobs right now in america so go find a
new job if they say no right make sure
to find one before you leave your
current job so you're not in a tough
situation where you start having to dip
in your savings your emergency fund
right the best time to find a job is
when you have a job but i don't think
bosses are handing out raises as easy as
people say but that's the point is the
job market is so competitive right now
from uh from an employer standpoint you
have to give people a 10 raise depending
on kind of how much it is on a notional
amount is much better for a manager in a
lot of situations call it the average
job in america than it is to go in the
opportunity cost of switching right the
amount of money and time and effort it
takes to go find someone that does a
similar job and that has to do with
quality that has to do with recruitment
that has to do with onboarding that has
to do with everything right and maybe
they're not even as good at the job but
ultimately a lot of managers i think
people would be surprised at you know a
five percent raise a seven percent raise
a ten percent raise is usually a much
better option for them than you saying
okay i'm gonna go get a different job
given the job market today